[Musique]
madeleine et sébastien chers collègues
bonsoir une semaine politique sous le
signe de la vaccination le fait saillant
de la journée astrazeneca et
l'approbation de santé canada pour cet
autre vaccin qui s'ajoute à l'arsenal
on va jaser mais juste un mois ce tour
d'horizon via un tableau je trouve très
important ça nous donne une idée de ce
qui nous attend nous et un l'ensemble la
population canadienne mars juin
septembre
voyez comment comment augmentent deux
fois en fois selon ses jalons la
quantité de doses de vaccins disponibles
et on parle juste ici des vaccins
moderne en phase ii et astrazeneca
voyez comment soudainement cette semaine
le portrait semble changer
madeleine parlons de ce qui est annoncé
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on doit retenir
on a un nouvel outil dans l'arsenal du
gouvernement c'est le vaccin
d'astrazeneca
donc c'est le troisième vaccin et qui
est à prouver on avait déjà sur deux
files heures et de modern à celui
d'astrazeneca
il faut le dire il est moins efficace
que ceux de que celui de father who que
celui de modern à celui astrazeneca donc
le nouveau vaccin approuvé est efficace
à 60 2 % selon les données disponibles
mais ce que nous ont répété les experts
de santé au canada aujourd'hui c'est que
62%
c'est mieux que rien et aussi que dans
les essais cliniques
il n'y a eu aucune hospitalisation aucun
décès parmi les personnes qui avaient
reçu les doses d'astrazeneca donc là
aussi c'est une nette amélioration par
rapport à aucun vaccin donc là est ce
qu'on a appris aussi du gouvernement
trudeau aujourd'hui c'est que on a un
contrat de 20 millions de doses avec
astrazeneca mais qui a eu un demi
million de ces deux là en fait ce sont
des dons supplémentaires nommé pour
simplifier les choses
un demi million de doses qui vont
arriver d'ici la fin mars
donc on sait qu'au début le camp les
doses arrive pas nécessairement
par grandes cargaison chaque dose des
comptes et là dans les parce que tu as
aussi les populations vulnérables qui
sont vaccinés en premier donc ces doses
leur compte et on en aura un demi
million de doses supplémentaires d'ici
la fin mais vous savez alexis le fait
que astrazeneca soit selon les premières
études moins efficace que les deux zones
d'accès ça a suscité des questions on a
su des questions aujourd'hui et jose
mendes qu'on peut choisir notre vaccin
quand on va se faire vacciner trois
questions comme sur un menu de
restaurant je préfère le faire je tiens
à 92 % plutôt que le astrazeneca à 62
ben non en tout cas au québec vous
n'avez pas droit de choisir le vaccin
qu'on vous injecte par contre une fois
quand vous la gérez vous pouvez demander
c'est quel vaccin comme à injecter donc
vous pouvez savoir quel vaccin a été
éjecté mais vous pouvez pas choisir et
l'a1 la semaine prochaine il ya
peut-être d'autres approbations qui vont
suivre
il ya deux autres vaccins qui sont à
l'étude en ce moment ceux de johnson and
johnson et de novavax ce que nous on dit
aujourd'hui les experts de santé canada
c'est que on va avoir probablement un
calendrier de d'approbation qui
ressemblent à ceux de nos alliés donc si
aux états unis où on a une approbation
par exemple de johnson & johnson faut
s'attendre à ce qu'à peu près en même
temps le vaccin soit aussi approuvé au
canada
donc pour ce qui est de 2 d'astrazeneca
je voudrais qu'on a entendu des jours et
des jours chaque jour je demandais à mes
contacts au gouvernement est ce que
c'est aujourd'hui parce qu'on nous avait
laissé entendre que c'est une question
de jours mais il ya de cela des semaines
mais ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
le gros de l'acheminement des vaccins
d'astrazeneca c'est dans le deuxième
trimestre donc à partir du mois d'avril
donc ils peuvent probablement moins
d'urgence d'une part et aussi c'est que
l'approbation devenait un peu plus
compliqué à étudier parce qu'on avait
non seulement les essais cliniques mais
il ya ailleurs en europe entre autres
des gens qui se sont véritablement fait
vacciner dans des vaccinale des
opérations de vaccination de masse donc
il fallait étudier aussi ces données là
où avant d'approuver le vaccin ouais
c'est un processus qui est long il
délicat mais qui est essentiel et
sébastien parent dont l'aspect politique
des choses parce que la dimension
sanitaire
ben ya un soulagement qu'on peut
présumer en ce moment dans l'esprit de
certaines personnes au gouvernement
trudeau au gouvernement trudeau
certainement parce que le le choc de
justin trudeau c'est d'amener des
vaccins puis il ya eu deux trois
semaines de flottement où
l'approvisionnement en vaccins étaient
couci couça et où il devait répondre de
ces contrats qu'il avait passé avec ces
compagnies pharmaceutiques place est en
train de s'accélérer et puis le fait que
les vaccins rentrer beaucoup au pays va
déposer sur les épaules des provinces la
responsabilité d'injecter ces deux là
est la question à partir du moment où il
y en a des millions qui rentre de doses
est ce que les provinces vont être
capable de suivre le rythme est de
vacciner les gens au québec en passant
c'est un chiffre peu connu mais selon
les dernières statistiques il ya quatre
cent mille personnes qui ont été
vaccinées mais à 500000 vaccins qui sont
entrés au québec depuis le début de la
campagne de vaccination
donc il y en a environ j'arrondis des
chiffres mais comme ils y dorment pas
les vaccins ils vont être vaccinés tout
ça mais il ya quand même un écart entre
le nombre de personnes vaccinées et le
nombre de doses reçues au soupir de
soulagement que doit pousser justin
trudeau le depuis quelques jours depuis
que les cargaisons arrive au pays
on faisait au gouvernement il ya
quelques semaines la quelqu'un disait on
est comme une voiture dans un lave auto
avec les fenêtres ouvertes en ce moment
et tant et aussi longtemps que les
vaccins n'arriveront pas on va rester là
ce lave auto là je vous dirais que les
fenêtres commencent à se refermer un
petit peu de la voiture ça commence à
aller mieux
évidemment il y avait d'autres défilent
et qu'on a vu cette semaine avec par
exemple l'arrivée à la frontière et
toute la la ligne téléphonique occupé
pour réserver des hôtels sas a pas été
si rondement que ça mais je pense que la
pression là que ressentait le
gouvernement il était beaucoup plus
forte
côté vaccination parce que là on parle
pas de quelques milliers de voyageurs on
parle de toute la population canadienne
qui attend ces vaccins mais voilà une
population qu'il ya aussi peut-être
senti un certain soulagement aujourd'hui
un début de quelque chose qui
ressemblerait à de l'espoir et mais
rapidement plus on avance puis à
d'autres
d'autres avenues qu'on étudie par
exemple certains passeports vaccin
portes ouvertes par monsieur dubé
entrouverte j'irai peut-être sébastien
est un peu refermée aujourd'hui de
guider nous un peu leurs proches ou à
québec 60 questions nuancé ils ont hier
monsieur dubé a clairement répondu à une
question d'un collègue journaliste qui
lui demandait ce qui pourrait vous
étudier la possibilité d'avoir un
passeport vaccinale pour fréquenter des
lieux publics puis je pense qu'il a
cités restaurants et salles de
spectacles institude jeu dubé a dit oui
mais ensuite il est parti sur la
technologie c'est à dire que ma
compréhension c'est que nos gouvernants
du québec on veut absolument que les
québécois aient accès facilement
rapidement à leurs preuves des
vaccinations pourquoi parce que s'ils
veulent voyager une fois vacciner à deux
doses
évidemment le poids juste à une dose
mais à deux doses certains pays pour
leur demander cette preuve des
vaccinations donc il faut que ce soit
accessible facilement et rapidement ça
c'est la priorité en ce moment
appréciant le gouvernement n'est pas
encore là mais il pourrait se poser
cette question là est ce qu'on a besoin
de blob 2 du fait du passeport vaccinale
pour rentrer dans un resto dans une
salle de cinéma dans une salle de
spectacle mais c'est pas la priorité ou
la première préoccupation la première
préoccupation c'est de pouvoir voyager
de sortie à puis de recommencer un
semblant de vie normale alors mais c'est
comme si on va mettre les énergies pour
que ce soit disponible sur le téléphone
la technologie soit au rendez vous pour
que ce soient facilement accessibles
on se posera d'autres questions plus
tard alors tous a eu des échos à ottawa
bien entendu madeleine et on a reçu on a
entendu une réponse donc sébastien
qualifié de mâle c'est sa ville d'agde
ou vagues peut-être avez-vous un
épithète un jeune étudiant
moi je dirais prudents préférant notre
spectre était prudent et on dirait que
justin trudeau s'acheter du temps d'une
certaine façon en faisant bon on va
poser cette question là aux experts il
disait il ya des avantages et des
inconvénients ce que j'entendais au
gouvernement - depuis quelques jours
quelques semaines déjà c'est que les
inconvénients sont quand même assez
lourds
premièrement je regardais les
statistiques n'y a pas trois pour cent
de la population canadienne qui ont été
vaccinés pour le moment alors imaginez
si on commence à imposer un passeport
vaccinale pour créer deux classes de
citoyens ceux qui ont le droit de faire
des certainement
évitez et ceux qui ont pas le droit il
ya la place de ceux qui n'auront
n'aurait pas le droit de faire certaines
activités seraient beaucoup beaucoup
plus grande que celle à qui on
permettrait certaines certaines
activités ou de voyager ou et ira donc
d'une part d'autre part ce qu'ont
indiqué c'est que la vaccination au
canada elle n'est pas obligatoire
donc on veut pas nécessairement créé par
la porte d'en arrière
ce qu'on ne veut pas affiché
publiquement par là de façon très très
officiel deuxièmement mais en même temps
aujourd'hui justin trudeau voulait pas
se montrer catégorique non plus
probablement en partie parce qu'il
voulait pas non plus rentrer dans une
petite guéguerre qui reçoit on essaie je
pense de très prudent de ce côté là
essayer d'éviter toute friction parce
que ça va mieux côté vaccination
quand on réussit à collaborer il ya un
consensus sur les voyages vous savez
vous voulez aller en asie en fait je
pense que c'est encore comme ça moi j'y
suis allé il ya une dizaine d'années on
avait besoin de vaccin et puis on avait
besoin de preuves d'avoir réussi vaccin
là donc il ya un consensus international
sur l'idée que parfois pour entrer dans
certains pays
ça prend des vaccins ce ne sera pas
différent avec la coved la question
litigieuse et qui fait débat c'est au
delà de ça est ce que ce passe par là va
être nécessaire pour accéder à des lieux
publics c'est ça la véritable question
comment et pour ce qui est des voyages
on n'est pas non plus à prioriser les
voyages en ce moment moi ce que
j'entends tout le temps c'est nos
voyages et passe pas le moment c'est pas
au top c'est un c'est un débat qu'on
pourra avoir dans quelques semaines
quelques mois probablement très bien on
m'a écrit hier monsieur tremblay laurent
tremblay mike et indien vous parlez au
panel de ce qui est arrivé de ce qu'on a
su cette semaine ses révélations sur
pierre elliott trudeau un petit petit
extrait de ses communications
diplomatiques
un télégramme comme on disait à l'époque
1976 il vous allez voir à l'instant et
c'est suite à la victoire du parti
québécois en 1976 l'idée serait de faire
passer le taux de chômage provincial de
10 à 15 % ou même 20 % l'année prochaine
deezer ou écrivez thomas sanders
ambassadeur américain à ottawa à ses
collègues à washington donc une
intention semble-t-il de pierres et de
trudeau de saboter en quelque sorte que
l'économie québécoise je vous entends de
là dessus
2 qu'est ce que ça éveille en vous ce
genre de choses qu'on déterre tant
d'années plus tard sébastien sa d'état
illustre à quel point je pense pierre
trudeau était frustré par ce qui se
passait au québec avec l'élection du
parti québécois
à tel point que il a parlé de cette idée
peut-être de faire mal à l'économie
québécoise pense pas qu'on peut mettre
en doute le câble diplomatique le
télégramme diplomatique de l'ambassadeur
qui quand ils transmettent ce genre
d'informations là il s'assure d'avoir
une information vérifiée véritable pour
donner un aperçu de ce qui se passe au
québec à leur patron ce qui étonne c'est
que pierre d'être doué voulu faire mal à
l'économie en sollicitant des gens
d'affaires dont les desmarais de power
corp région pour arriver à ses fins ça
ne s'est pas produit par qu'on ait
démarré par un record 10
on n'a pas transféré d'activités à
l'extérieur du québec et le taux de
chômage a atteint 15 20 % non plus alors
ça fait partie de la politique mais ça
nous en apprend peut-être un peu plus
sur la personnalité de monsieur trudeau
à cette époque madeleine et ça nous
apprend des pans de notre histoire moi
je trouve ça toujours intéressant mais
c'était aussi intéressant de constater
que des questions qui ont été posées à
justin trudeau
cette semaine là dessus là sur cette
histoire que ma collègue elizabeth
thompson de siby ci avait d'abord publié
et là c'est une toute une autre question
est ce qu'on peut faire porter le poids
de choses qui se serait passé il ya 44
ans à un premier ministre actuel qui est
le fils de pierre elliott trudeau
probablement pas c'est probablement un
juste d'aller de la sorte
évidemment justin trudeau porte le nom
de son père c'est lui a probablement
donné certains avantages il a été
davantage connu ça vient avec un bagage
évidemment mais il faut aussi faire la
part des choses et probablement que les
électeurs vont la faire cette part des
gens très bien
c'est en tentant de la thur avec la
semaine prochaine la semaine de relâche
à québec pose à l'assemblée nationale et
à la chambre des communes n'est ce pas
chez lui aussi relâche bon ben laden
moins de temps pour étudier le projet de
loi sur lesquels à mourir après un
quatrième report
ouais et nous nous on attend peut-être
mardi la conférence de presse sur
l'après relâche c'est vrai avec possible
restriction con con finalement conte
comment on pourrait dire ça qu'on
desserre finale voilà qui est dit merci
beaucoup baden et sébastien aussi
fatigué besoin de la semaine de relâche
allez au revoir vous me direz pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit